I'm gonna start crying sorry
it's been really stressful
um you know it was a lot of stress on me
to learn a different Arrangement and
then just come out here so yeah I'm
sorry American Idol contestant fire
breaks down in tears as Kaya Stewart
quits the show just moments before their
duet it's gonna bring uh emotions out
and that could come in the form of Tears
anger surprise during Monday night's
episode Kaya the daughter of eurythmic
singer Dave Stewart paired up with fire
to perform a collab of Adam Lambert's
what do you want from me but when Kaya
got sick she bailed on the audition
leaving fire to fend for herself so
we're not performing today means I'm no
longer gonna be in the competition
yeah
I I have to leave I'm sorry I'm I'm
really sorry
just so wild of course fans of the show
will remember fire who first auditioned
with her three-year-old daughter by her
side she's a handful but she's also my
best friend do you want to come sit up
here with us while mommy sings come
right here this way the 22 year old
single mom who wants to quit her job as
a stripper and provide a better life for
her little girl performed Bruno Mars's
Talking to the Moon but it didn't wow
Lionel and Luke I'm sorry hmm it's a no
for me
I fire gosh I'm so sorry uh it's going
to be a no for me
but Katie told fire to come back and
audition for the show in
Nashville
Iris
exactly what she did getting a yes from
all three judges after she's saying
Adele's love in the dark
Flash Forward to Hollywood week
and the judges were right there rooting
for fire as another contestant took the
stage to sing alongside her oh you got
this you got this
listen fire
you're not going to be abandoned anymore
we support them we nurture them we give
them constructive criticism a crash
course a fast
crash course
of the music industry
[Applause]
[Music]
I shouldn't give a damn
[Applause]
fire gave it her all and had Katie in
her feels
[Music]
proud of you
you're growing
little by little
you can't control a lot
you can control yourself
control your future thank you for
standing up here and continuing to try
thank you for swinging
thank you for not forfeiting
Thank You For Fighting we just like
teach them everything we know in all of
our years and even if they don't win
American Idol they go home just like
full of so much hope but Fire doesn't
have to worry about going home just yet
and in this moment we get to control a
little bit of your future you're going
forward fire thank you
[Music]
foreign